so once you have a good understanding of
this the problem you move to the define
stage could you tell us a little bit
about that yeah I love the define stage
so we started not by rushing to
solutions but by understanding second we
moved to something that would be
absolutely amazing and favorite for
everyone who likes analysis the define
stage is about finding a strategy and
analyzing what is the best path to
actually arrive at the solution during
this stage all of the exercises that
someone is familiar around product
strategy becomes very very applicable
let's list a few examples the define
stage can be greatly enhanced if people
pause to describe the user journey that
they're working to create for the user a
user journey is a storyboard that helps
define the major pieces step by step of
someone experiencing the product from
the very first time when they don't know
anything about it towards the time when
they become a masterful user and they're
maybe even evangelizing it to their
friends so I actually need to write what
the user name is and what do they do
with the app well that's that's a great
question another you might not need to
have a user name for the user journey
what we're trying to find is what is the
most common path that someone would take
from a perspective of not knowing
anything towards being able to use it
over and over again now within that
there may be other stories for example
if you're working on an app that's
reviewing local restaurants there may be
one journey for people who are writing
the reviews and another journey for
people who are reading the reviews from
those two the most common paths would be
someone hearing about your app hey
there's this great local app this but
this can be in a newspaper this can be
in a restaurant and you need to plan for
that we don't plan for that discovery
moment it's just not gonna happen
so you look at release how are people
discovering my up after that it's about
how are they starting to use it what
that may mean that they download it and
then afterwards they're starting to
search for restaurants read about them
and then they get reminded tough that
they be somewhere potentially that they
need to write a review so let's say the
most common path
the user journey has many names in the
industry because design is a relatively
new discipline in technology there has
been many different ways to refer to
that some people refer to the user
journey as a storyboard in fact what we
know from design history is that Disney
was the first person to use storyboard
right didn't he have a team of artists
and technologists who had to make the
first animated movies before anyone knew
how to make that so in order to keep
everybody on the same page and not to
waste money
he created the storyboard that said
moment after moment what is happening to
his characters and that first storyboard
which was about the movie Snow White
helped organize his team and set a
precedent that teams continued to use
today so if you're using a storyboard
you have Disney to thank for that
and a quick follow-up on that so how do
I know that I have enough stories that
I've completed all the stories so this
is a great question the user journey is
the user there's one central story that
is the most important another name for
that is the golden path that actually
comes from Microsoft in Microsoft or so
the story goes the teams refer to the
golden path is the experience that is
absolutely key for the product to work
for the users to come and get what they
want the golden path is supported by red
threads these are the little stories
that help make it possible and there can
be many many little little threads such
as the user sign in potentially the
shopping experience but if the discovery
if this is your golden is the golden
part is your discovery process then
that's what needs to be really easy
really key and all effort in the company
need to be focused there so why is it
important to be clear of one most
important user journey well we believe
that it's important to prioritize and if
you don't if you don't know what your
app is is going to be most commonly used
for that it's really difficult to know
how all the other things fall out so we
recommend to always focus on one central
user journey and to make sure that it is
easy and effortless for people to
achieve that it's important to plan for
everything we see a lot of stars sail
because there's created a great product
but they
have any plan for how they're going to
be discovered in that way they're
building little islands in the ocean and
there's no liner that will ever take
passengers there this is why we remind
people plan the entire journey plan your
product in all of the different stages
from the time when no one knows about it
towards the time when they really
masterful